for decades the classic VW bus lovingly
known as the bully in Germany has been
an icon of 1960s flower power life on
the road and freedom 405 VW buses of all
generations from the t1 to the t5 have
converged from the Baltic Sea Island of
fame on for the midsummer bully festival
the beach party lasts for four days the
function of it is simply getting
together with people and driving around
this is a piece of German culture
cultural holders yes it's part of my
life I drive it up start to go surfing
and at these meets you see people you
know it's a little community familia no
vacation with friends and family you sit
together and chill out talk about VW
buses we talk shop oh my you're living
an original or one that's been modified
it's just fun to be with all these
people hardly any other van of its class
is as versatile it can be individually
customized for travelling hobbies or
leisure activities a custom-built
extended rear for extra cargo space or
it can be converted into a pickup we've
converted the vehicle to be utilitarian
but also usable as a leisure time car
I've customized them professionally for
27 years so I made a career of my hobby
and now I've made a hobby of my career
again now it's back to just being my
hobby this is hope easily hits it a
highlight of the festival is the parade
the participants form a convoy and drive
over to the mainland and through the
villages along the coast wherever they
go people are excited to see them it's
all about seeing and being seen
if load of quality people are happy to
see you and they way with big grins on
their faces I don't think any other car
makes for such thrilled and happy faces
and that's somehow satisfying you put so
much effort money and love into it and
then when you get responses like this
when you get all these smiles and thumbs
up it's beautiful macomb justice mangala
he appeared in this dumb ones of us
should it's one big celebration of the
VW bus and its fans but not everyone
here has been bitten by the VW Bug some
are here with other mates we've
converted our mercedes sprinter into a
camper van we're looking for ideas for
small cars our sprinter is fairly small
because we travel to Norway a lot so
we're here to gather ideas and there's
no shortage of inspiration and ideas all
around
some of the buses have undertaken a long
journey back to their German roots
does this in Mexico know this is a 1995
Mexican build t to see it was built in
Mexico until nineteen ninety five then
production went to Brazil you can fall
in love with a piece like this you have
to put something into it it's been
restored twice but it's a true friend a
member of the family when taken care of
VW buses just seem to keep going and
going and going
as a member of the family the VW bus
needs its tender loving care this is
where the girls from the car wash come
in they clean wax and polish the paint
till it shines just look at this darling
it's magnificent while some keep
scrubbing others kick back in their
buses on mobile cafe
yet another infamous team the bus was
going to be cannibalized but it was
still in good condition and we thought
we had to do something with it we had to
give some fun to what we wanted to do
sometimes admissibility unfuckin in
germany the vehicle inspectors have to
approve all vehicle modifications the
inspectors folded everything out and
folded it all back in again and made
sure it wasn't too wide we're not
allowed to drive on public roads like
this but once everything is stowed away
it's classified as a load and that makes
it street-legal like a typical VW bus
fan they bring their own folding sofa to
the party there's still enough for other
parties on other beaches
you